طلب الاتحاد الافريقي على لسان مدير اداره
الصراع في مجلس السلم والامن الافريقي طلب
بوقف فوري لاطلاق النار في السودان اضاف
المسؤول الافريقي في اجتماعي اللجنه
الدوليه الموسعه الخاصه بالسودان بان طرفي
الصراع لم يلتزم باتفاقيه جدا لوقف اطلاق
النار كما ندد باستمرار استهداف المدنيين
وعدم الالتزام بالقانون الانساني الدولي
محذرا من تاثيرات الحرب في السودان على
دول الجوار بدورها طلبت
ممثله منظمه ايجاد في اجتماعي المجتمع
الدولي بالعملي على طلبات المجتمع الدولي
بالعمل على ايقاف القتال وانهاء معاناه
الشعب السوداني ويهدف اجتماع اللجنه الذي
يعقد او يعقد بمشاركه احدى وعشرين دوله
ومنظمات دوليه واقليميه الى وضع خارطه
طريق الاتحاد الافريقي للازمه السودانيه
بمشاركه الشركاء الدوليين والاقليميين
ديري مكتبنا من اديس ابا محمد طه التوكل
محمد هذا الاجتماع للاليه الموسعه لبحث
تطورات السودان وانت تغطيه ما ابرز ما تم
تسجيله حتى الان وهل هناك اي ردود فعل حول
هذه الانباء بتعليق الجيش لمشاركته في
مفاوضات جده
نعم سهام الاجتماع انتهى قبل قليل وفي هذه
اللحظه من خلفي بدا المؤتمر الصحفي لمدير
ديوان الاتحاد الافريقي وايضا المسؤول من
ملف السودان في الاتحاد الافريقي
السهام الان
الاجتماع انتهى
ودمه الامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي
وايجاد والجامعه العربيه
وتم التوصل الى خارطه الطريق اتفقت فيها
الجهات الاقليميه والدوليه لحل الازمه
السودانيه والخارطه الطريق التي تتكون من
خمسه صفحات واطلعت عليها الجزيره الان قبل
دقائق معدوده هذه خريطه طريق ستكون هي
ملزمه للمجتمع الدولي للالتزام بحل الازمه
السودانيه وهي توحيد جهود المجتمع ابرز
البنود في هذه خارطه الطريق وقف اطلاق
النار بشكل دائم وليس بشكل مؤقت ثانيا
قوات دعم السريع وال المسلحه عليهم ان
يلتزموا التزام نهائي
ثالثا اشراك قوه المجتمع المدني والمقاومه
اللجان المقاومه والمجتمع لانه هناك مشكله
حقيقيه المعارك منحسره في داخل الخرطوم
حتى لا تمتد الى المناطق الاخرى هناك في
اليات لالزام كافه الاطراف للوصول الى
الاتفاق مع الترحيب بالمبادره السعوديه
والامريكيه ولكن هذه القاعده ترى ان توحيد
الرؤيه العامه وثم اتخاذ اجراءات لازمه
لاي طرف يتولى عمليه خرق ما يتم الاتفاق
اليه وسادسا طبعا اتخاذ قرار مهم ارسال
فريق من
التنسيقيه الدوليه الخاصه بالسودان الى
السودان واجراء اتصالات وزياره دول الجوار
التحرك بدل ما جمع المعلومات التي كانت
حتى هذه اللحظه فبالتالي بعد هذا
الاجتماع ستكون هناك تحرك وايضا سيسموا
الاشياء بمسمياتها وايضا ودعوا اللجان
واليات للتاكد من الخروقات ومن الانتهاكات
والاضرار التي لحقت بالسودان وهنا قلق
حقيقي
لما يلحق بالمدنيين في السودان فبالتالي
وصلت
مساعدات مقدمه مرطبيه وغيرها الى مدينه
مدني
ودواحي قرطوم لم يتمكنوا من ايثالها
فبالتالي وادعوا اليات وهذا اول مره
المجتمع الدولي يتفق سهام على رؤيا وخارطه
الطريق خاصه بالم الاتحاد الافريقي وبقيه
شركاء الدوليين فبالتالي سنرى ردود
الافعال لكن مساله رفض اي طرف من الطرفين
ما يتم طرحه سيكون هناك بحضور مجلس الامن
الدولي في هذا الاجتماع ستكون هناك
اجراءات ثانيه ما لم يتم ايقاف قتل
المدنيين في السودان سهام نعم محمد طه
توكل لمدير مكتب الجزيره في اديس ابابا
شكرا لك